La fealdad envolvente
de nuestros entornos cotidianos en Estados Unidos
es la entropía hecha visible.
No podemos sobrestimar la cantidad de desesperanza
que estamos generando en lugares como éste.
Principalmente, quiero persuadirlos de la necesidad de hacer algo mejor
si vamos a continuar el proyecto de civilización en Estados Unidos.
A propósito, esto no ayuda.
Nadie la está pasando mejor debido a esto.
Hay muchas formas de describir esto,
a mí me gusta llamarlo "el tugurio automovilístico nacional".
Lo puedes llamar desfachatez suburbana.
Me parece más apropiado llamarlo
la mayor equivocación en la asignación de recursos en la historia del mundo.
Lo puedes llamar un revoltijo de las externalidades de la tecnosis.
Y es un problema tremendo para nosotros.
Para nosotros, el problema sobresaliente
es que estos lugares no valen la pena.
Vamos a hablar de eso un poco más.
Un sentido de lugar.
Tu capacidad de crear lugares significativos con calidad y carácter
depende totalmente de tu capacidad de definir el espacio con edificios,
y emplear los vocabularios, gramáticas,
sintaxis, ritmos y patrones de la arquitectura
que nos indiquen quiénes somos.
El ámbito público en Estados Unidos tiene dos roles:
Es donde vive nuestra civilización y nuestra vida cívica,
y es la manifestación física del bien común.
Cuando degradas el ámbito público,
automáticamente degradas la calidad de tu vida cívica,
y el carácter de toda materialización de vida pública y comunitaria que allí ocurre.
En Estados Unidos, el ámbito público se manifiesta por lo general en la forma de la calle,
ya que no tenemos las milenarias catedrales, plazas
y mercados públicos de culturas más antiguas.
Y tu capacidad de definir el espacio y crear lugares que vale la pena cuidar.
proviene de una corriente cultural que llamamos la cultura del diseño cívico.
Este es un cuerpo de conocimiento, métodos, técnicas y principios
que botamos a la basura después de la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
y decidimos que ya no la necesitamos; no la vamos a usar más.
Por consiguiente, podemos ver los resultados a nuestro alrededor.
El ámbito público nos tiene que indicar no sólo dónde estamos geográficamente,
sino que nos tiene que indicar dónde estamos en nuestra cultura.
De dónde venimos, qué clase de personas somos, y tiene que --
-- al hacer lo anterior, tiene que darnos un vistazo de nuestro rumbo
para así poder vivir en un presente alentador.
Y si hay una tremenda --
si hay una gran catástrofe en los lugares que hemos construido,
los entornos humanos que nos hemos creado en los últimos 50 años,
es que nos han privado de la capacidad de vivir en un presente alentador.
Los entornos en los que vivimos, típicamente, son como estos.
Resulta que esto es el cinturón de asteroides de la basura arquitectónica, a 3,2 kilómetros al norte de mi pueblo.
Y recuerden, para crear un lugar de carácter y calidad,
tienen que ser capaces de definir el espacio.
¿Y eso cómo se logra aquí?
Si se paran en la salida del supermercado "Wal*Mart" acá,
y tratan de mirar hacia el supermercado "Target" de allá,
no lo pueden ver por la curvatura de la Tierra. (Risas)
Así es como la naturaleza nos dice que estamos definiendo mal el espacio.
Como consecuencia, estos son lugares en dónde nadie quiere estar.
Estos serán lugares que no valdrá la pena cuidar.
Tenemos como, ¿saben? como 38.000 lugares
que no vale la pena cuidar en Estados Unidos.
Cuando tengamos suficientes de estos, tendremos una nación que no vale la pena defender.
Y quiero que piensen en eso cuando piensen en
esos jóvenes que están en lugares como Irak,
derramando su sangre en la arena.
Pregúntense, ¿Cuál será su último recuerdo del hogar?
¡Espero que no sea el corte de andén entre el restaurante "Chuck E. Cheese" y el hipermercado "Target"!
Pues eso no es lo suficientemente valioso como para justificar el derramamiento de su sangre (Aplausos).
Necesitamos mejores lugares en este país.
Espacio público. Este es un buen espacio público.
Es un lugar que vale la pena. Está bien definido.
es enfáticamente un salón público al aire libre.
tiene ese algo que es terriblemente importante --
tiene lo que llamamos una membrana activa y permeable en sus bordes.
Esa es una forma elegante de decir que tiene tiendas, bares, cafés, destinos --
-- las cosas entran y salen. Es permeable.
La cerveza entra y sale; las meseras entran y salen;
y eso activa el centro de este lugar, convirtiéndolo en un destino en el que la gente quiere pasar el tiempo.
¿Saben? En estos lugares en otras culturas,
la gente va allá voluntariamente porque les gusta.
No necesitamos una feria artesanal aquí para lograr que la gente venga. (Risas)
No necesitan un festival "Kwanzaa".
La gente simplemente va porque es agradable estar allí.
Pero, así es como se hace en los Estados Unidos.
Probablemente el mayor fracaso en espacio público en Estados Unidos,
diseñado por destacados arquitectos del momento, Harry Cobb e I.M. Pei:
La Plaza de la Alcaldía de Boston.
Un espacio público tan deprimente que ni los borrachos perdidos quieren ir allá. (Risas)
Y no lo podemos arreglar porque I.M. Pei aún está vivo,
y cada año Harvard y M.I.T. hacen un comité conjunto para arreglarlo.
Y cada año fracasan, pues no quieren herir las susceptibilidades de I.M. Pei.
Este es el otro lado del edificio.
Fue ganador de un premio internacional en diseño en, si mal no recuerdo, 1966, o algo así.
No fue Pei y Cobb. Otra firma diseñó esto.
Pero no hay suficiente Prozac en el mundo para que la gente se sienta bien al caminar por esta cuadra.
Esta es la parte posterior de la Alcaldía de Boston,
el edificio cívico más importante en Albany -- perdón -- en Boston.
¿Cuál es el mensaje que emite?
¿Cuáles son los vocabularios y gramáticas que provienen de este edificio?
¿Y cómo nos informa sobre quiénes somos?
Por cierto, este edificio estaría mejor si pusiéramos retratos en mosaico
de José Stalin, Pol Pot, Saddam Hussein,
y todos los demás dictadores sanguinarios del siglo 20 en este costado del edificio,
pues así estaríamos expresando honestamente lo que el edificio realmente nos comunica.
¿Saben? Ese es un edificio déspota;
que quiere que nos sintamos como termitas. (Risas)
Así se ve a menor escala.
La parte trasera del centro administrativo municipal de mi pueblo, Saratoga Springs, Nueva York.
A propósito, cuando mostré esta diapositiva a un grupo de Kiwanianos en mi pueblo,
todos se levantaron indignados dejando su pollo cremoso. (Risas)
Y me gritaron, diciendo:
"¡Estaba lloviendo el día en que Usted tomó esa foto!"
Porque se percibe meramente como un problema climáctico. (Risas)
Este es un edificio diseñado como un reproductor de DVD. (Risas)
Salida de audio, fuente de energía --
y miren, saben que estas cosas son importantes trabajos arquitectónicas para las firmas. ¿Cierto?
Contratamos firmas para que diseñen estas cosas.
Pueden ver exáctamente lo que pasó, a las tres de la mañana en la reunión sobre el diseño.
¿Saben? Ocho horas antes del vencimiento del plazo,
cuatro arquitectectos tratando de terminar este edificio a tiempo. ¿No?
Están sentados aquí en la mesa larga en la sala de juntas
con todos los dibujos, y las propuestas,
y todas las cajitas de comida china dispersas sobre la mesa, y --
Quiero decir, ¿Qué tipo de conversación sucedió allí? (Risas)
Porque ustedes saben cuál fue la última palabra, la última frase que se pronunció en esa reunión.
Fue: "¡A la mierda!". (Risas) (Aplausos)
Eso -- ese es el mensaje de esta forma arquitectónica.
El mensaje es: ¡Nos importa un carajo! Nos importa un carajo.
Entonces, volví en el día más agradable del año, sólo para --
ya saben, hacer una prueba de realismo.
De hecho, él ni siquiera entra porque --
no es lo suficientemente llamativo para sus clientes,
ya saben, los ladrones, los asaltantes.
No tiene suficiente riqueza cívica para que les interese pasar por ahí.
Bueno.
El modelo de la "Calle Principal EEUU" --
por cierto, este modelo para la construcción de manzanas en el centro, es bastante universal, está en todo el mundo.
No es tan complicado --
edificios de más de un piso, construidos hasta el borde de la banqueta,
para que la gente -- todo tipo de gente -- pueda ingresar al edificio.
Se pueden realizar otras actividades en los pisos superiores,
ya saben, apartamentos, oficinas, y demás.
Se facilita esta actividad llamada "hacer compras" en el primer piso.
Eso no lo han aprendido en Monterey (California, EE.UU.; sede de la conferencia).
Si van a la esquina de la intersección principal justo en frente de este centro de conferencias,
verán una intersección con cuatro paredes en blanco en cada esquina.
Es realmente increíble.
Bueno, así es cómo se compone y se arma un edificio comercial en el centro,
y esto fue lo que ocurrió en Glen Falls, Nueva York,
cuando intentamos hacerlo otra vez, donde hacía falta. ¿Cierto?
Lo primero que hacen es levantar el comercio medio nivel sobre el terreno, para que sea deportivo.
Bien. Eso destruye por completo la relación entre el negocio y el andén,
donde se encuentran los peatones teóricos. (Risas)
Por supuesto, nunca estarán ahí, siempre que estén en esa condición.
Como la relación con el comercio se destruyó,
forzamos allí una rampa para discapacitados,
y luego, para calmar nuestras consciencias, ponemos una curita de naturaleza en frente.
Así es como lo hacemos.
Las llamo "curitas de naturaleza" porque hay una idea generalizada en Estados Unidos
de que el remedio para el urbanismo mutilado es la naturaleza.
De hecho, el remedio para el urbanismo herido y mutilado es el buen urbanismo, los buenos edificios.
No solamente camas de flores, no solamente caricaturas de las montañas de Sierra Nevada.
¿Saben? Eso no es lo suficientemente bueno.
Tenemos que hacer buenos edificios.
Los árboles que bordean las calles realmente cumplen cuatro labores, y eso es todo.
Delimitan espacialmente el ámbito peatonal,
protegiendo a los peatones de los vehículos en la vía,
filtran los rayos de sol que alcancen la acera,
y suavizan la dureza de los edificios
y crean un techo -- un techo abovedado -- sobre la calle.
Eso es todo. Esas son las cuatro funciones de la arborización callejera.
No se supone que sean caricaturas del Bosque del Norte;
no se supone que sean el escenario para "El Último Mohicano".
¿Saben? Uno de los problemas con el fiasco de los suburbios es que destruyen nuestro entendimiento
de la diferencia entre el campo y la villa, entre lo urbano y lo rural.
No son lo mismo.
No vamos a curar los problemas urbanos al arrastrar el campo a la ciudad,
lo que muchos de nosotros intentamos hacer todo el tiempo.
Aquí ven a pequeña escala -- ha aterrizado la nave nodriza,
R2-D2 y C-3PO (robots de la película Star Wars) han salido a probar el estiércol de corteza
para ver si pueden habitar en este planeta. (Risas)
Esto se debe, en gran parte, al hecho de que la ciudad industrial en Estados Unidos fue tan traumática
que cultivamos esta aversión tremenda hacia la idea completa de la ciudad,
la vida urbana y todo lo relacionado con ella.
Así, lo que ven relativamente temprano, a mediados del siglo 19,
es la idea de que hay que tener un antídoto para la ciudad industrial,
que será la vida en el campo para todo el mundo.
Y eso se comienza a dar en forma de la comunidad de ferrocarril del suburbio:
la villa campestre sobre la ruta de ferrocarril,
la cual le permite a la gente gozar de las ventajas de la ciudad,
pero volver al campo todas las noches.
Por cierto, en ese momento no tenían ningún Wal*Mart o almacenes de cadena.
De verdad era una forma de vida campestre.
Pero lo que sucedió, por supuesto, es que mutó los siguientes 80 años
convirtiéndose en algo bastante insidioso.
Se convierte en caricatura de la casa campestre, en una caricatura del campo.
Y esa es la gran agonía no-pronunciada de las afueras de las ciudades,
y una de las razones por la que se presta para el ridículo,
ya que no entrega lo que ha prometido por medio siglo.
Este es el estilo de vivienda que típicamente se encuentra aquí, ¿saben?
Básicamente una casa con nada al lado,
pues la casa quiere declarar, enfáticamente,
"soy una pequeña cabaña en el bosque. No hay nada a mi alrededor.
No tengo ojos a un lado de mi cabeza. No puedo ver".
Entonces, ven esta última fachada de la casa,
ell frente, que realmente es una caricatura de la fachada de una casa.
Porque - noten aquí la terraza.
Salvo que las personas que vivan aquí sean enanitos, nadie la va a usar.
Esto es, en realidad, un programa de televisión de emisión continua llamado "Somos normales".
Somos normales, somos normales, somos normales, somos normales.
Por favor respétenos, somos normales, somos normales, somos normales.
Pero sabemos lo que está pasando en estas casas. ¿Saben?
Sabemos que el pequeño Skippy está cargando su metralleta Uzi aquí abajo,
en preparación para el gran ataque y escape. (Risas)
Sabemos que Heather, su hermana Heather, de 14 años,
se prostituye aquí arriba para sostener su hábito de consumo de drogas.
Porque estos lugares, estos hábitats,
están generando cantidades inmensas de ansiedad y depresión en los niños,
y ellos no tienen mucha experiencia con medicamentos.
Suelen tomar la primera sustancia que se les presente, frecuentemente.
Estos lugares no son lo suficientemente buenos para los estadounidenses.
Así son los colegios a donde los mandamos:
La Escuela Central "Hannibal Lecter", Las Vegas, Nevada.
¡Este es un colegio real!
Pero obviamente hay esta noción que si dejan que los reclusos salgan de esta cosa,
ellos raptarían a un motorista de la calle y comerían su hígado.
Entonces, se hace todo el esfuerzo para mantenerlos dentro del edificio.
Noten que la naturaleza está presente. (Risas)
Vamos a tener que cambiar este comportamiento, nos guste o no.
Estamos entrando a una época de cambio en el mundo, y -- ciertamente en Estados Unidos
-- ese época será caracterizado por el fin de la era del petróleo barato.
Eso va a cambiar absolutamente todo.
Chris me pidió que no me extendiera demasiado en este punto, y no lo haré.
Salvo para decir que no habrá una economía de hidrógeno.
Olvídenlo. Eso no va a pasar.
En lugar de eso, vamos a tener que hacer otra cosa.
Tendremos que reducir, reorganizar y redimensionar
casi todo lo que hacemos en este país, y es imposible comenzar este proceso demasiado temprano.
Tendremos que -- (Aplausos) -- tendremos que vivir más cerca de nuestros lugares de trabajo.
Tendremos que vivir más cerca los unos de los otros.
Tendremos que cultivar alimentos más cerca de donde vivimos.
La era de la ensalada César cutlivada a 5,000 kilómetros está llegando a su fin.
Tendremos que... ¡Tenemos una red ferroviara que sería una vergüenza para los búlgaros!
¡Tenemos que hacer algo mejor que eso!
Debimos haber comenzado dos días antes de ayer.
Tenemos la fortuna de que los nuevos urbanistas estuvieron, durante los últimos 10 años,
desempolvando toda la información que se había botado a la basura
por la generación de nuestros padres, después de la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Porque vamos a necesitarla si vamos a aprender cómo reconstruir pueblos.
Tendremos que devolver este conjunto de metodología y principios y competencias
para así volver a aprender cómo componer lugares significativos -- lugares que sean íntegros.
Que permitan -- que sean organismos vivos en el sentido de contener todos los órganos de nuestra vida cívica,
y nuestra vida en comunidad, desplegada de forma íntegra.
Para que las viviendas tengan un uso lógico
en relación con el comercio, la cultura y la gobernanza.
Tendremos que volver a aprender cuáles son los cimientos de estas cosas.
La calle. La cuadra. Cómo componer espacio público que sea tanto grande como pequeño.
El patio. La plaza.
Cómo hacer uso verdadero de esta propiedad.
Podemos ver algunas de las primeras ideas
para mejorar algunas de las propiedades catastróficas que tenemos en Estados Unidos.
Los centros comericales muertos. ¿Qué vamos a hacer con ellos?
Pues, por cierto, la mayoría no lo van a lograr.
No serán retro-acondicionados;
van a ser las chatarrerías del futuro.
Pero algunos serán arreglados, creo.
Y los vamos a arreglar imponiendoles nuevamente los sistemas de calle y manzana,
volviendo al lote como el incremento normal del desarrollo.
Y si somos afortunados, el resultado se verá en pueblos y barrios con centros revitalizados
en nuestros pueblos y ciudades existentes.
A propósito, nuestros pueblos y ciudades están donde están, y crecieron donde están
porque ocupaban todos los sitios importantes.
Y la mayoría seguirá estando ahí,
aunque su escala probablemente se disminuirá.
Tenemos mucho trabajo pendiente.
No nos va a rescatar el híper-carro; no nos van a rescatar los combustibles alternos.
Ninguna cantidad o combinación de combustibles alternos
nos va a permitir seguir manejando lo que estamos manejando, en la forma en que lo estamos manejando.
Vamos a tener que hacerlo todo de una manera diferente.
Y Estados Unidos no está preparado.
Estamos caminando sonámbulos hacia el futuro.
No estamos preparados para lo que viene hacia nosotros.
Les insto que hagan todo lo que puedan.
La vida a mediados del siglo 21 se centrará en vivir localmente.
Estén preparados para ser buenos vecinos.
Estén preparados para encontrar vocaciones que los hagan útiles
a sus vecinos y conciudadanos.
Una cosa final -- Esto me ha perturbado por años,
pero creo que es particularmente importante para este público.
Por favor, por favor, dejen de referirse a ustedes mismos como "consumidores". ¿Vale?
Ser consumidor no es lo mismo que ser ciudadano.
Los consumidores no tienen obligaciones, responsabilidades y deberes
hacia sus prójimos.
En la medida en que usen la palabra consumidor en la discusión pública,
estarán degradando la calidad de la discusión que estamos entablando.
Vamos a seguir siendo ignorantes
al entrar a este difícil futuro que encaramos.
Entonces, muchas gracias.
Por favor salgan y hagan lo que puedan para que esta tierra se llene de lugares merecedores de nuestro cuidado,
y una nación que vale la pena defender. (Aplausos)